ronnie is a superstar he attended
something the nhra four wide national
drag race in las vegas and he ended up
getting interviewed on fox sports one i
thought i should really
yeah
and ronnie was showing off on this
interview on fox he uh talking about how
he was in a suite he's drinking vodka
this is the interview how'd you end up
there one of your little racing car
buddies huh ron capps is an nhl racer
he's been on the wrap-up show a few
times he's a fan of the show so no
howard it wasn't one of his racing
buddies who invited him no it was the
guy it's one of my racing buddies who
invited him i said he's a fan of your
show
i said that already when i saw the video
of you i said what the [ __ ] going on
with ronnie he looks so different what
did he look like well honestly he looked
very old in the interview but i realized
what it was ronnie gets dressed up for
these race car events and he's wearing
like a racing cap an erasing shirt
that's what makes me look older is that
[ __ ] hat and i know it does yeah so
it was warm out the sun was strong and i
didn't want to get burned on my head but
also the shirt and everything you dress
like a 12 year old kid who's going to
disneyland oh and i'm supporting the
shirt
shirt but the shirt didn't fetch it for
christmas
you got to get a t-shirt that fits no it
fits believe me the shirt fits the
t-shirt the hat looked like you were in
line for the teacup ride at disneyland
a 72 year old boy why okay listen i had
a good time that's all that mattered
okay all right this is ronnie's
interview on fox it's world exclusive
here
i noticed a couple of things ronnie was
having a hard time getting the words of
vodka and soda out
and also uh ron morani gets nervous his
voice kind of shakes he gets like all
shaky my whole body's shaking from the
vibration of these cars ronnie mund who
you may better know as ronnie the limo
driver from the howard stern show out
here supporting his friend ron capps
experiencing four wide nhra drag racing
for the first time i know you've been to
nascar races
what is your perception of the power
that comes from 44 000 horsepower well
all i know is my whole body is shaking
inside and that kind of scares me but
i'm enjoying it it's a lot of fun first
time i've been out to the line over here
and it's really been cool the first run
i watched up in somebody's suite had a
vodka and soda a lot that was a lot
better but this is much more fun being
down in the action great to have ronnie
bond out here this weekend for howard
stern fans pretty cool moment there
i got to tell you there's so much to
dissect i was so terrible what was so
terrible about who mentions i was in a
suite and i had vodka and soda who you
mentioned
it was a joke
that's the joke
ron laughed
[Laughter]
i was just trying to bring out that i
was enjoying the day is that okay
all right all right i was just pointing
out i was more comfortable up there
having a vodka and soda watching it from
the sweet i wasn't having vodka and soda
when i was or something
oh stop jesus
hey ronnie what do you think of the race
vodka and soda
the sweet i have to say it's sweet yes
sweet it was awesome sweet sweet
sweet all right thank you ronnie puppet
thank you ronnie and congratulations
thank you big interview yes thank you
very much i had a great time
congratulations ron capps and you know
why my voice shakes because i chase the
cars like a dog when they go down the
track
such a
weirdo such a weirdo